[Applaudissements]
si vous nous rejoignez les chéris sachez
que l'émission peut s'arrêter à tout
moment basculer le full time as roma
liverpool je dirais pas en voir on sera
peut-être en peine phrases et been seen
on s'intéresse à exactement bon séjour
c'est vers là je suis en train de parler
là enfin voilà donc on n'est vraiment
pas au courant ou nouvelle gamme arthur
king ou alors vous justement ce soir
vous êtes payé quand on s'arrêtera au
départ fera elle fera une règle de trois
tout ça on posera x salaire de benhaim
voilà moi jean luc chérie ça va très
bien c'est jean luc tu es une de mes
fiertés de ces dix dernières années
c'est vrai ouais tu sois prêt non c'est
vrai elle fait plaisir
participer au mariage montrer des trucs
sympas de moi 4/3 ça m'arrangerait bien
sûr la fierté et va tomber vite c'est la
volée question c'est surtout une
question à l'époque et surtout de suite
bonjour je m'appelle irène suite à son
accident de scooter mathieu a dit dans
l'émission qu'il était revenu transformé
personnellement je le trouve toujours
aussi prétentieux
est ce normal
[Applaudissements]
je comprends votre étonnement il règne
mais il faut pas prendre tout au pied de
la lettre
mathieu revenu transformé oui mais ça se
joue sur des détails par exemple avant
il aimait le pognon maintenant ils
préfèrent l'argent voilà à transformer
complètement non plus mais c'est vrai
qu'il nous a tous fait peur avec son
histoire de scooter et alors je sais pas
c'est vrai question je sais pas si tu as
vu l'émission qui a suivi ce malheureux
accident
quand si les adresses de tes nouvelles
pour la première fois pour rassurer les
gens non c'était très très émouvant et
moi ce que je préfère c'est pourquoi
cyril a pensé à le faire à ce moment-là
ça s'appelle un réflexe conditionné un
matin en fait c'est mon doigt qui
arrivait de changer que des postes très
fort à mathieu il admis et bien sûr nous
pas l'émission qui allait il a fait sa
légende à sur nrj12 qui entendent
aboiements et quand ça vous fait vous me
donne des nouvelles de mathieu désy
c'est mignon mais vous l'aviez vu vous
ouvre sur nrj 12 artistes ou virgin et
adore cette émission elle en blu ray non
c'est vrai que j'adore à la dore
valadeau regarder et l'allée et
franchement vous avez vu les deux les
deux là il est deux meilleurs amis du
monde d'un côté les deux meilleurs amis
du monde mais on parlait tout à l'heure
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bon alors c'est un cheminement complexe
sur votre série love mais c'est aussi ça
qui la rend si brillant par exemple
c'est le seul animateur qui bat de
traduire en mots très simples n'importe
quel témoignage regarde ce qu'elle a dit
séverine vieira toujours très mignonne
ouais du vx alors est ce que cette
histoire avec faudel était une
paparazzade ou une véritable histoire
d'amour
ça a été un coup de coeur je peux pas
d'enfants pas senti une vraie tendresse
j'ai beaucoup de tendresse pour lui on
s'est revus à l'école traduction c'est
bien c'est direct quelle vulgarité
non mais attends mais il n'est pas du
tout c'est ça veut rien dire à bosser la
cassure au calme et vocale mais vous
s'il vous plaît merci
la question qu'on peut se poser c'est un
esprit aussi brillant supporter la
contradiction oui évidemment évidemment
qu est ce qu on est là pour débattre
qu'est ce qui est le cas ce qu'elle à la
hague a tu penses que je franchement
merci à tous et à toulouse c'est sarah
du tout la contradiction est ainsi
tester ça va faire de raccourcis comme
ça et je suis pas d'accord il est
d'accord pour dire que je déteste le
contraire rien à [ __ ]
tu vas tomber à nous non non mais nous
tombait à nous il va avoir un push sur
morandini
alors il a bien débattre la preuve la
semaine dernière avec jean michel jean
michel qui n'étaient pas d'accord écrit
pas trop regarder ce qui s'est passé là
la désigner les sens et pas une cage
choisissent après qu'aaron brésil loi
française qui l'obligé et là vous forcez
et alto rire elle était connue comme ça
la loi nous donne un réseau qui peut
être vers 6h15 et toi qu'en 2006 on dit
n'importe quoi
c'est incroyable l'ultime tour mais
accepte quand on n'est pas tombé ça
puisse avoir du sens sinon on n'aurait
pas de mon avis c'est que c'est pas vrai
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jocard ses coûts devrait lui comme il me
parle
non mais ça les deux là ouais j'ai en
face à face jamais construit a le dos
tourné il ya beaucoup de proches broyée
pas notre genre de caméra ils étaient
face à face à baisser les yeux
d'abaisser les yeux et je peux te dire
qu'il a terminé à eux alors vous savez
que quand vraiment je fais les yeux
noirs c'est le moment où lui-même il
arrête et quant à un oeil au beurre noir
aubry et pierre maury pub
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
à ces machines ces machins image bien
sûr qu'on vous dit comment at il fait
pour atteindre un tel degré de
perfection qui lui permet de dire
posément quand on n'est pas de mon avis
c'est pas bon il a atteint ce degré de
perfection à force de travail et de
remises en question
peu de gens savent chaque jour avant
chaque émission syrie se fixe un
objectif qui consiste en un petit jardin
secret et est pas prêt pas il devient
d'un meilleur voilà l'homme que vous
avez devant vous en exclusivité j'ai pu
me procurer ces objectifs de la semaine
dernière c'est très impressionnant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vais dire aux cépages fait ces
derniers jours
quoiqu'on en dise il montre du jour
elle a besoin
ces genres toi c'est chaud là bas tous
convoitent un moteur
[Musique]
la journée
agir là dessus on à scoop également de
maxime kenny et oui une fois n'est pas
coutume on aura peut-être un truc
intéressant d'isabelle et un scoop de
maxime oui c'est une émission
exceptionnelle
non
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
vous me pardonnerez monsieur le ministre
mais l'émission mais c'est pas lui qui
produit non mais on n'est pas ministre
un ans que je ce crétin d'état pense que
je vais dire sait pas trop qui vous
attend
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas trop de coups d'état à key west
voisenon mais l'epa secrétaire d'état et
le son je pense que tu as osé le dire
tout à l'heure basées à bosser un peu
vos émissions bosse un peu des émissions
lui et moi entre lui et moi
revoir après l'émission dans les
sanctions chef à la nation y aura des
sanctions
alors christophe castaner qui était venu
avec son staff et notamment une jeune
femme qui était sur le plateau pendant
la pub et là j'ai pris une leçon non je
dois l'avouer je suis assez timide
bon je sais pas aller vers les gens que
je connais pas j'avais peur de passer à
quoi leur dire et vie de me retrouver
comme un conte à rien dire et ben maxime
il m'a montré comment faire à lui il a
une facilité engager la conversation
ça force le respect l'un des plus beaux
échanges de la semaine
[Applaudissements]
alors vous le savez sans doute valérie
bénaïm est très pudique concernant sa
vie privée
oui c'est vrai c'est la tâche elle
partage son quotidien et qui a un clown
portant le monde patoche je vais suivre
et c'est pas un nom de secrétaire d'état
donc comme elle est très pudique quand
il raconte quelque chose de personnel
être ensemble un peu la réalité pour pas
trop en dire là par exemple syrie lui
demander de réagir sur la polémique
concernant adriana karembeu qui portait
encore le nom son ex mari christian le
problème c'est qu'en face elle avait
monsieur premier degré matthieu
delormeau a ri quand tu épouses ton mari
bon vous avez repris benhaim mais je
n'ai jamais quitté niamey ils sont pris
ils s'appelaient il s'appelait mais
lorsque je me suis mariée ça le fait que
votre qui s'appelait marie s'appelait et
sape les vallées les y voilà
et donc je me suis rappelé valérie
benaïm zizi mais n'ont donc on n'est pas
obligé de prendre le monde sont les son
mari nommé les haies et donc ensuite
après vous appeliez médaille misy
exactement les cieux on passe maintenant
au point johnny on a tenu ce qu'ils
disent ce qu'on veut
cuvée millions
[Applaudissements]
tous les deux on est comme ça oui au
bois vos mots je suis ici bas seulement
sa troisième femme s'était nathalie fou
mais je veux pas me moquer parce que
c'est pas facile et toujours au top
prend les chroniqueurs fossard qu'être
chroniqueur c'est beaucoup de
responsabilités bac de stress par
exemple mathieu encore dit merde je
disais il peut plus avoir une relation
amoureuse normal et ça ils avaient
besoin d'en parler parce que lui faut le
reconnaître les mois pudique que valérie
benaïm
[Musique]
blanc et tout mais là dessus dit il pour
les hommes tandis que j'ai connu six
appareils
le
guerrière une dernière autour de voir un
corps musclé tout du niveau sonore que
les charismes dès que nous sommes tous
d'accord musclé to do that ans à vous
intéresser à tout ce qui m'intéresse
oui et j'en tire la wii a en tout cas
elle entend pas non ma grand mère c'est
trop mignon mais vous ça vous arrive et
sans incident jeudi il ya bien longtemps
quand voyez vous quand vous pouviez
batifoler un peu avant d'être fidèle et
marié salle de bain quand on a un peu
connus construire ou sera bel et bien là
n'étaient pas connues oui c'était pas
comme irwin et pas de cap pas marié n'a
pas encore tous dur aujourd'hui ça me
récupère un jour férié
je vais y penser pour les prochaines aux
autoroutes y a un truc sinon la semaine
dernière celui diffusé le dernier
concert de michel sardou
ah ouais vous rappelez hannon et pour
l'occasion tp avait décidé de passer à
chaque retour pub une chanson du grand
michel 1 le problème c'est que les
images ça coûte cher
donc comme ils sont rois décision à la
prod il avait fait venir un imitateur il
était subalternes ya pas de crise
économique n'a pas été très très bien en
plus heureusement parce que je vais vous
dire la vérité
juste avant la première prestation cyril
a eu un doute mais non dès les premières
notes cyril a compris qu'il ait fait le
bon choix
regardez ses yeux émerveillés ils aient
eu l'impression que le vrai michel
sardou était là
[Applaudissements]
où
[Musique]
son prix
ça a bien roulé à faire j'étais dedans
après je fais partie ont fini avec le
top j'ai danse cette compilation des
petits moments étranges de tpm paix mais
vous êtes vous n'êtes pas jean fievet
vous avez un gentil avec moi mais c'est
de l'amour ou l'âge je vais m mais non
ce sera moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
personne n'a pas de danse il faut faire
ces voleurs voleurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ado c'est le chant des municipaux fait
râteau
c'est bientôt l'heure de l'apéro les
chevaliers
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le téléphone
tu dis merci bien
certains
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour
tu
[Musique]
j'ai envie d'avoir mon avis oui / sekla
gatti comme vous êtes j'avais de bonnes
relations en ce moment ouais ouais ouais
oui mais c'est vrai que quand on met un
décolleté ou cours montre ses fesses on
sait très bien pertinemment quoi l'art
est gérée on n'est pas d'accord avec les
réseaux sociaux mais on sait que ça va
arriver donc fois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
doivent-ils bisous c'est un succès c'est
qu'on prend pas en compte cette virée
[Rires]
dans le club
[Applaudissements]